[Applause]
[Music]
that right there is some serious silence
she
[Music]
Taylor opened the show singing the man
wearing the titles of the older album
she's been battling her former label big
machine over but then she decided to
shake it off
[Music]
as et predicted the epic performance was
full of girl power
Camila caballo Hongzhi and ballet legend
misty Copeland all took the stage
I'm a huge music fan and so it's
exciting to be able to be a part of this
last night Taylor also broke the record
for the most AMA wins ever 29 the last
year of my life has had some uh just
like hardest things I've gone through in
my life and not a lot of them are things
that haven't been public Taylor's bestie
Selena Gomez opened the show and took a
lot of heat on social media
[Music]
you too
many accused her of being off-key and
off her mark while dancing some reports
claimed she had a panic attack before
taking the stage
however our et source says she was quote
definitely nervous and a little panicked
but it was not an attack last night's
double winner Carrie Underwood cried a
little pretty herself she broke an ama
record for most wins for favorite
country album thank you so much you guys
and before to time I am a winner Billie
Eilish lit the stage on fire I
introduced her to another boldly dressed
Billie on our et platform but our AMA
award for most unexpected fanboy moment
let goes to the DJ Diplo he could barely
even handle meeting Shania Twain
[Music]
legend oh my gosh this is amazing I'm
starstruck I'm starstruck this is great
I don't know what to say
[Applause]
I've had this actually on hold for me
for a while and I'm bringing it out
tonight
[Music]
Valentino feather moment I was in New
York buying the wedding dress for my
daughter's wedding and I saw this
sweater now I'm wearing at the VMAs
Easter antique section tailor rocking a
deep green beaded gown with over the
knee boots but was there a hidden
message in her custom design look the
artists of the decade seem to be giving
off total reputation vibes well some
fans thought she looked like money but
Liz's message was loud and clear with
her super tiny custom Valentino purse
strutting the red carpet in peachy
ruffles before hitting a stage in
raspberry tulle the internet thought
Billy's jeweled headpiece was a cross
between The Handmaid's Tale and a
beekeeper suit but what you might have
missed on the red carpet Selena's new
tattoo
she showed off her new ink on the gram
right before the AMAs - hands clasped in
prayer with rosary beads cascading down
her leg side note it looks a lot like
the one her ex Justin Bieber has the
Cape Ball games all the bad the most
expensive look on the carpet dancer
alison stoner in a 2.4 million dollar
crystal covered suit that took six
months to make Carrie Underwood's
thigh-high slit gave us serious leg envy
but Jameela Jamil gets our vote for best
accessory of the night what's in this
tiny bag there is this usual icky string
[Music]